so I have a strategy called Damn the
Doritos I think when you're on a diet
that the typical advice people give you
is get rid of all the junk food from
your house and I think that may be a
good start but I think it's a crutch
because what ends up happening is you go
on vacation you go hit a cruise ship
office party whatever you're just
Downing all of the food so you I'm
teaching myself that I can only win
inside of a perfect little environment
which I didn't like so my vice is
Doritos I love I want to eat this right
now every time I look at it I Pat myself
in the back mentally of like damn the
Doritos that that I am stronger than the
Doritos and we all have a Doritos in our
life whether it's actually Doritos or
sugar or some habit or something that
distracts us we all have these things
that um every time I look at it though
it now makes me feel like I'm doing the
right thing I'm I'm building the person
that I'm proud of myself so when I look
back on my life like yes I'm I'm proud
that I make those difficult choices so
hey it's EV Carmichael and I watch these
videos every day because I need them for
motivation being around successful
entrepreneurs every morning helps me
believe that I can do great things too
it's like your morning coffee but for
your goals kickstarting your day with a
blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
# believe in the comments below so I can
celebrate with
you so today let's learn from me and my
team's take on my top 10 rules of
success enjoy rule number two is have
more courage you probably don't need
more learning and you need more
courage more boldness what doing to do
the thing right and this is where a lot
of people will get stuck up is like oh I
need to learn more I need to learn more
I need to learn more I need to learn
more there's so many people like if
learning was the only thing that
mattered then yeah then University
professors would all be the richest
people in the world right I mean it's
like and the most successful and but
they're not because learning alone is
not enough it's the doing and so the
most important part of morning routine
is the feel feeling you get by the end
of it you know if you're thinking about
how you even started ask who you want to
be you said I want to be you started
with I want to be a great father then
you said I want to be a great husband
then you said I want to be a a role
model for my community right so that's
actually the order of priorities if I'm
you I look at if you just went and you
work this job that you you know you
don't like and you're trying to figure
out a way kind of to transition out of
uh how do you make sure you show up at
home to be the best husband and the best
father h
it's probably not listening mov
Mak maybe I don't know I don't know if
we talk much about
that like to get the vibe right so so on
the way home maybe it's actually better
to listen to something else a parenting
podcast uh medit uh we don't meditate on
the way home if you're driving but
something that makes you want to be a
better father and a better
husband but you don't even need action
steps like you don't need need to
necessarily listen to a podcast to say
here are the eight ways to be a better
husband if you just felt like walking in
the
door I've put my work behind me for now
and I want to be a great
husband you'll come up with ideas of
what to do and you'll just be a better
husband as opposed to having to learn
how to be a better husband rule number
three is believe in yourself fail okay
great go so you buy a stock and a tanks
is that that means you're done you're
never going to invest ever again or if
the ETF has a bad month what you sell
and then you're you're out I mean you
have to keep going you got to keep
learning this is a forever game that
we're playing here and successful people
do that and the ones who don't reach it
there's nothing there's not that much
that's different like they're not more
talented they're not more skilled
they're not more they're definitely not
smarter they believed in themselves when
they shouldn't you know when they air
quote shouldn't they started
and it just kept going and here they are
and I think that's why the mission
becomes important like why are you doing
what you're doing it's got to be
something that in the face of constant
failure you're still going to get up and
keep going because you love the thing so
much rule number four is be persistent
so I broke my neck uh and everybody said
go home okay it's time to go home uh but
I couldn't fly because the pressure that
the airplane creates you can't fly with
a broken neck and the doctor said I had
a 50% chance of spinal surgery which was
scary think about spinal surgery um but
I said I'm going to keep going I want to
keep going I want to at least try like
why is the answer just a stop without
even trying so I said my my stop was in
Denver and I had to cancel it because I
was in the hospital but I said okay what
tomorrow we can just we refund everybody
the money that they paid and just like
have them all come over to where we're
at and I'll just do it lying down and
the guy the doctor's like dude you have
a con he didn't say dude but he said you
have a concussion you cannot do this
like okay fine so we canel we just
completely canc and refunded everybody
understood obviously I mean I'm in the
hospital uh broken that concussion but
my favorite part was in Kansas City that
was our next stop so instead of just
going home let's just try let me try
Kansas City I don't want to just default
the giving up and so I was wearing this
and I didn't know if I'd be able to make
it or not so we already we refunded
everybody who showed up to Kansas City
and and then we message him and say hey
uh we already booked the hotel room like
the the venue we can't get that money
back um I'm coming to Kansas City anyway
so how about we just you just come for
free and we'll jam and and it'll go as
long as I can go you know so it wasn't
the usual four hours about four hours
three four hours on one my sessions and
so we get there and my wife nah is like
not happy she doesn't want me doing this
uh and she's eyeing me it's like she the
deal was I would go if if she had
control to pull me off because I
wouldn't pull I would never pull myself
like I would I would faint again right I
would just just go until I passed that
so the deal was I would go until she
said
no uh and I ended up going an hour and a
half and I knew that she was paying
attention to how dry my lips were
getting so I probably should have quit
about 45 minutes in but I kept licking
my lips just to make sure that they were
moist so that she wouldn't pull me off
but an hour and a half in uh she said
okay we have to stop this now's like I
was starting to slur my answers and it
wasn't it wasn't great but it's like
I've never been pulled off of
like that was I was at my physical Max
that was it and a lot of times when we
hit um when we say no we're not we're
not actually at our Max you could you
could go probably a lot more if you just
if you just went through it if you just
told yourself that you can and so that
was probably my worst speech of the
whole tour but it was my favorite
because like I had actually nothing left
I had to be pulled off a stage and say
goodbye to everybody and then I had to
wear this for the next I what whatever
that was 56 days um but I'm proud that I
did it like it wasn't my best speech and
every session got a little bit better as
I I mean doing a presentation with a
concussion is uh pretty rough I never
had a concussion in my life before but
I'm really proud of myself that I did it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the work she designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is surround
yourself with greatness if you think
about who Your Role Models or heroes are
and just trying to be around them more
whether it's virtually or in person I
mean you're here you know learning from
me learning from the group um but
virtually too who are the people who
help push you to be the version of Hardy
that you're really proud of you know
like the ultimate version of Hardy uh
for me that's why I still make the
videos on my channel like the top 10
videos I make for me cuz in the morning
I want Oprah in my ear and Elon Musk in
my ear and Steve Jobs in my ear because
no matter how great a day that I had
it's still starting up every day like
today is great today is like okay we got
Mastermind we're going to film it's easy
to get up for today right I barely slept
last night I just so excited to come in
here and be with you guys but on a on a
normal day it's like you're waking up
and there's nobody telling you what to
do and there's no kind of Boss over your
shoulder and sometimes it's hard to
connect to the big mission and and
so having something you mentioned
environment having something that you
feed into yourself that makes you want
to step up and play a bigger game rule
number six is Embrace opportunities the
willingness to say yes to the next thing
because I'm not trapped by what I said I
was going to do in my three-year plan
three years
ago but it's got to be big like it's got
to be towards the mission I want to
solve the world's biggest that doesn't
change I want people to believe in eles
more that will never change so the next
thing I do it's like maybe it's not
YouTube anymore right at some point
YouTube's been a great run but if clay
and I are doing this in 10 years we're
going to be in each other's living rooms
or something you know we're going to be
in our VR headset or hologram world or
whatever right so it's not being so
attached if my if my x-y year goal was
to have X number of subscribers on
YouTube I think that's a silly goal
because three years in maybe I'm
supposed to be jumping off of YouTube
and and starting a company with clay
changing the world in VR yeah ready to
hop on the next opportunity whatever you
know follow in service of the
mission but that's terrible financial
planning right oh bitcoin's here so let
me just put all my money in Bitcoin
right like you have to know Trends and
and you
know you but you have to have a solid
plan like if if you're looking at this
as your life like you need this money
for the rest of your life you're
creating the plan for yourself then you
have to have more long-term for casting
and you can do that to to a high degree
in the finance world you can't do it in
in entrepreneurship and life rule number
seven is make connections pay attention
to where they're the person you're
trying to Target is themselves
personally if you tried to get a hold of
me through my main YouTube channel or
even through Instagram it it would be it
would be rough cuz because I have
barriers up because lots of people
trying to access me that way on my
YouTube gaming channel right now there's
I don't know eight people who show up in
the chat consistently right so like if
you're one of those eight and you're
giving love I'm going to pay attention
to you right and I stream for an hour
and a half to two hours four times a
week typically and if you're there you
you have access to me uh and so you
reverse engineer that whoever you're
trying to get where are they spending
their most time right now and you want
to be there giving love giving value you
could you could be on my LinkedIn all
day long posting great comments and
feedback I'm just not seeing it right
just because that's not where my
attention is right now so that's that's
step number one step two is once you get
something so you got this with me now
you should look at who is following me
on
Instagram and then doing Outreach to
them to say hey we had EV Carle on do
you want to come on and you know Evan
Carle means nothing to most of the world
but to people who follow me on Instagram
they know who I am if they're already
following me they're following me for a
reason they may not know who Mark is yet
but oh Evan was on okay that's cool I
might let's maybe I say yes and if
you're trying to get after somebody
bigger um you know if you wanted to have
Grant Cardone on I would look at
everybody that Grant follows on
Instagram and there'll be some big names
who will be impossible to get you know
the Rock and whoever else but there's
going to be a bunch of smaller names on
there too who would actually be super
easy to
get and if you have something that you
like about their story so now you know
follows me on Instagram if you had me
and then you had three or four other
people that Grant followed who are
smaller who you may not have heard of
before but they came on your show and
again it's it's not just about the biz
de to get the grant they have to have a
story they have to have something that
you know authentically you would want to
share with your audience right it's not
just for the for the access but if you
got four of those people on and then you
reached out to Grant to say hey Grant we
had these four people on do you want to
come on next it's a much higher chance
of a yes cuz oh all these people said
yes who I follow and I
know he's much more likely to say yes
rule number eight is take risks saying
yes to the opportunity even though it
doesn't make any sense and your brain is
like fighting you don't do this stay
with the job stay at UPS you know it's
hot but you're making money you have to
pay rent like you can you have a
paycheck right versus I'm going to go
and seize the opportunity to take the
risk so it was a risk I remember I met
with Alex a couple times over like late
night uh walks side to talk about it and
I don't want to force anybody into
something that's not a fit for them talk
to his fiance at the time and like
getting her blessing and seeing what
making sure everybody would be happy and
then he decided okay I'm going to I'm
going to take the risk and I'll say yes
and that was I don't know s years ago I
don't know how long ago that was nine
years ago wow you know and so now like
biggest Salsa School in the country
maybe again North America they lots of
upward growth potential what we're
creating see otherwise now he be who
knows selling some other interact
machine door too door somewhere hating
his
life right like taking the risk right so
again but you don't know because when
you look at the website you come through
the studios looks successful if you came
at night you'll see a whole bunch of
students here dancing having a good time
you assume Alex grew up and was a great
dancer and learned this all his life and
it's like no he sucked it was the worst
rule number nine is do what you love
time is scheduling things so Thursday is
my public facing day so I'm doing all my
interviews and podcasts and hangouts and
some people that works and some people
that doesn't like if you didn't agree to
do a Thursday this may not have happened
because Thursday is your whatever
swimming day or something I don't know
so that plays well because I have
different days for different things and
then stress comes down to doing work
that you love so I love my days not
every moment of every day you know like
if my microphone breaks or my camera is
out of focus or I fall off my trampoline
or something right like stuff's going to
happen every day that you don't love but
net you love it where if I was an
accountant I would hate my life and be
stressed out constantly because I don't
like doing accounting but I like doing
this so this isn't stressful for me this
is fun for me but for somebody else it'd
be the most stressful thing of all time
so the things that are causing you deep
stress uh would highly question whether
you should even be doing those things or
if there's something better for you that
you want to chase down and number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is start taking action I think the
biggest problem for most people is they
just never start if you're listening to
this and you want to start investing you
start I get it it's scary you can make
mistakes but you've got people like clay
and the guests coming on to help you and
give you guidance and and teach you but
you'll never get ahead by sitting on the
couch and never doing anything right so
many people sit on great ideas even if
even if all you do is buy an ETF and
sitting there for five years it's better
than sitting here doing zero and then
five years later looking back and say ah
man I wish I did that five years ago
we're stuck living in regret instead of
actually doing something making a change
so I think of financial education a lot
of like I wish my parents taught me this
or why why didn't we learn this in
school how does school not teach us how
to invest and take care of us great I
mean so you didn't learn it in school
learn now right like that that's not
going to change anything for you so the
only thing that will change is taking
some kind of
action a lot of people quit so early on
their career and they never get the feel
the impact of cuz this is more
meaningful than a million views on a
video cuz what does that mean where
somebody and all of us feel not just me
like if somebody came up to you and said
hey what you do touched me you know the
art that you made touched me inspired me
moved me and and the whole point of art
is to make people feel whether it's a
painting or a speech or a video or you
know beautiful design you know camera
it's like art makes people feel and so
we're all creators we're artists and so
when somebody comes up to you and says
hey your creation helped me feel
something help grow Help Me Grow help me
expand help me help me feel empowered
encouraged Unstoppable belief like
whatever even even if for like a moment
the fact that you made something that
then touch somebody else's life that's
why we do what we do like we all want to
wake up and feel like we're doing
something that matters and is Meaningful
having an impact so when somebody comes
and tells you that that's more the thing
that you'll hold on to and remember not
that I hit X number of views on a video
being in the industry so long watching
so many like if you think about what I
do and how many videos I watch of how
many successful people they all have
some core themes to them and whether
it's entrepreneurs or athletes or
artists or musicians or whoever they
have similar themes and and you know
turning lemonade or turning lemons into
lemonade you know turning a negative
into a positive is is a consistent theme
across everybody and so I think it just
it happened
subconsciously just by being in the
environment of having those people
around me virtually to the point where I
was doing out exercise being forced to
sit with negative thoughts and it it I
had changed but I didn't notice like I
don't there was no moment of coming out
of the Cocoon and now I'm a butterfly it
just slowly became here I am as a
butterfly gotcha so it was just going
through the process yeah it's it's like
imagine if you were working out your
legs every day you don't you don't you
don't see a day-to-day difference right
there's no one moment like oh you did
one extra hard set and now you've got
these Rippling calves ready to go right
but I think the only difference was I
wasn't
even consciously training it was just
because it was in my environment and I
think that happens for a lot I think
that happens for most people just in a
negative way you're constantly watching
news and Twitter streams and all of this
negativity and all of a sudden you know
you start to become a negative person
because of all the things that are
happen around you but it's not that you
can pinpoint one thing that that was the
moment you became negative or even
notice that you're becoming negative
it's just happening and so that's the
power of when you shift your environment
and you're controlling what you're
consuming into your you know into your
brain so I was conscious what I was
consuming I wasn't conscious about a lot
of the transformation
that happened as a result it's only in
looking back or doing exercises like
that um that I notice the difference my
biggest challenge on a day-to-day I'd
say now is not accounting or doing um
you know grunt work or things I don't
want to do it's more pushing harder you
know I think good is the enemy of great
and so things are really good and and
it's honestly great I mean if you look
at a a Global Perspective everybody
listening into this show is in a great
like you have internet you know globally
you're you're way ahead of a lot of
people um you have food you have a bed
so you're you're way ahead already of a
lot of the world but but you could do
more and that's the biggest push that's
why I need Jay-Z in my ear and Oprah
Winfrey in my ear and and Steve Jobs in
my ear and these people that's why I
make the videos I do because it's easy
to wake up and just keep doing the same
it's hard to wake up and push yourself
to do something that you haven't done
before to to believe in the next version
of what you could become and that's um
that's an ongoing struggle the hardest
step is the first step you know like
once you start your first video it's
easier to do another video and another
video but once you start moving it's
easier to just to stay in momentum than
to to go from nothing to that first step
and similar to your story a lot of
people sit on anide idea they take six
years to take the first
step and then when they take the first
step they just keep going it's just like
just don't wait six years next time take
six minutes and just start right and so
one of the things that I love to try to
do is go from idea to action so when you
get an idea just do some small version
of it just get started I had an idea for
a podcast when I was driving through I
was on my tour in
2019 and I'm driving through the desert
in Texas and this idea to start a
podcast with my friend Mark drer and why
am I thinking about Mark in Texas all of
a sudden I hadn't talked to him for a
while and why do I want to start a
podcast with them normally it would be
overanalyzing judging thinking I don't
have time to do this right now I'm on
tour I got a million things I have to do
I'll do this when I get back to Toronto
in in another eight weeks right it's
like there's no time to do this right
now but I've taught myself to do the
opposite that idea to action so uh I'm
driving my wife nah is beside me and
said Nina we need to get a hold of of
Mark you know let's let's message Mark
and so we we grab him on a call and I
told him about the idea for the podcast
he like I'm in like let's do this as
soon as you get back to Toronto I'm
gonna start getting ready for
preparations it's like Mark that's two
months away man I'm not
doing by that time it's like that's like
a decade away dude I'm not waiting two
months to do this like well when do you
want to start it's like what do you mean
today like what do you mean today like
today we're GNA I'm going to drive to
get into my Airbnb I'm going to hope
they have good internet and we're going
to launch the first show today it's like
but I don't even know what we're going
to call it I don't know what we're I
don't know what the first Topic's going
to be I don't know how we're going to
intro this like all the things that
start it's like well Mark I'm gonna be
there in 90
minutes figure it
out and then I got to the Airbnb we
figured out the internet and we had our
first show and was it was it great no
but the most important thing was you
take the first step SEO is different in
the YouTube game people think think of
YouTube as the second largest search
engine in the world which it is but most
of the views don't actually come from
search it'll come from brows and
suggested which means either the YouTube
homepage or if you type in something on
search uh how to Market my business
somebody's going to rank there and get
that video click but then from your own
experience you'll watch that video and
then you'll watch the videos down the
side and you'll watch the videos that
show up after much more than you'll go
back to what we're under the search term
so you might get one view from search
but then you get eight nine 10 more
views from suggested down the side so
the real game is not ranking for search
the real game is ranking after the
videos that are ranking for
search suggested so so the way to do it
for anybody this is a great hack for
anybody who's you know who's listening
watching um think about who is the
number one person in your industry what
kind of videos are they making and then
going in looking at what kind of content
they're creating
and then take almost the exact same
title and make your version of that
video not I don't care what's in the
video I don't care what they're talking
about or how they're doing it because
you're the expert you're the thought
leader I want your opinion all I want
you to do is take that title because
your goal is to rank after that person's
video so they just watch them so if it's
a marketing video uh you know maybe you
watch a Gary V video like how to mark it
on Instagram in 2020 uh and then you
call it the same video the same I want
them to watch Gary and then I want them
to watch you and that's how you start
siphoning audiences and amplifying your
voice what advice would you give to
those individuals that want to develop
that relationship to their consumers
their fan base yeah I mean I think a lot
of it I guess comes across a strategy
but it's more even the one I just give
with my wife that's a strategy hey don't
go to bed angry but it's more like I
can't go to bed angry because I'm not
gonna sleep right so it's not it's not
even a strategy it's more of a a
necessity yeah yeah exactly so
so the short answer is just care right I
mean care about the people for me it's
always been about who is in front of me
instead of who's not as much as I want
to grow as much as I want to get to 10
million subscribers or a billion views
or whatever for the impact that it's
having it's still always about who I am
serving instead of who I'm not and I
think that's where most people make the
mistake is you look at your downloads
and then you look at Joe Rogan's
downloads you're like oh my God like I'm
nowhere close I or your YouTube views
against mine or somebody else it's like
I suck I'm nowhere close um I did a I
have a movement makers program uh which
I train I do training twice a month to
help entrepreneurs build their movement
and today we were looking at people's
hundreds videos like their hundredth
video on YouTube so my 100th video had
like 190 views and three comments my
100th video Gary V's 100th video had 800
something views and three comments 100
videos in right and so how do you keep
going that's a 100 videos that's not
like just four
episodes It's because 130 people or 190
people would ever watch that video
that's 190 people if you gonna go up and
give a speech in front of 190 people
you'd be you'd be jazzed you'd be
excited you'd be scared you'd be nervous
like oh my God I want to let them down
the people but because it's online it's
like ah that sucks only 190 people
compared to all these other people so
it's great to want the growth it's to
strive to improve and progress and get
better and and you always want to keep
getting better and the priority is the
people who currently are watching
listening because if you treat them
great I mean the strategy side is hey
you treat them great they'll tell more
people they'll come back you win for me
it's just been you're here I love you
like let's make this count whether it's
you know whether whether you're the only
person who ever listens to this or
there's a million people who end up
listening to it when I'm speaking in
front of 2,000 people it's great when
I'm speaking in front of four it's great
it gets to be more intimate and personal
right like I love you thank you for
being here thank you for giving me your
time and I hope to leave something with
you that helps you live a better life
right like it's that's the mindset
everything else follows the strategy
then follows right I'm struggling to
keep on top of everything like I can't
respond to every comment um I have
people on my team who help me with it
too but even on Instagram I'm still
trying to every new message that comes
in yesterday I was doing a whole bunch
of them at at you know 11:30 at night
hey thank you so much for that message I
really appreciate you thank you for
sharing my message with your audience
believe right that 8C clip because
somebody shared my story to their story
I don't know how I didn't even check how
many followers ah had maybe it's three
and it's their mom and their sister and
their brother right great you shared
your story with your audience thank you
um I don't know I just I like it dude I
just like it I I don't know that it's a
strategy for everybody so I think you
have to be that kind of person what is
your number one tip or strategy to help
us sell more understand your most
important goal and then create the show
that helps you accomplish that goal like
YouTube can serve you in a lot of
different ways most people think of it
just as a place to be an influencer and
build a brand and and it is if you want
long-term success building a brand and
having people beat a path to your door
is huge but that doesn't happen in you
know 30 days
uh so if your number one goal is I need
to make sales in 30 days cool start a
YouTube show around Business Development
let's go close how do you determine who
to interview or who's top 10 to put
together I have to learn something from
it so everybody that we've profiled I've
I've learned something from them and
this is where I think a lot of people
get messed up is that you only want to
learn from one kind of person where I
think the real unlocking comes when
you're willing to learn from people who
maybe you hate 98% of them but there's
one thing that they can still teach
you so you know I've got Steve Jobs up
on my wall and I've got my parents up on
my
wall I don't want to be a father like
Steve Jobs was a
father right he he wasn't a very good
one at least one that I don't aspire to
be like I want like my father
was but I don't want to be a Visionary
like my father was cuz he's not and he's
not an entrepreneur I want be Visionary
like Steve Jobs was and so you you your
ultimate goal is not to be the next
anybody it's to pull different things
from different people to be the best you
right right so um I have Kanye up on my
wall back there and Kanye used to bother
me a lot in my my younger years like I
didn't like the bravado and the ego and
and the brashness and all that but
there's still a lot of that um there's a
lot you can learn from Kanye and so
everybody that I profile on the channel
is something that I personally learn
something from that I've gotten a
takeway and if we if I can't then we
don't publish there's a lot of people
that people have said hey you should do
this person and that person and this
person we have thousands and thousands
of requests from people to do I see them
in the comments Lots I mean every day we
get hundreds every day it's it's wild
I'm super fortunate um but if I if we're
researching them and I can't I haven't
learned something from them then we
don't make the video we want a
consistent thumbnail design so here I'm
looking at another movement maker Bo Xin
he has been crushing it with his show
and bringing in deals uh he just landed
another deal that was 30 or $40,000 as a
result of having a guest on his show so
something we teach inside the movie
makers program is to do a bis Dev show
think about the people that if they knew
who you are would lead to revenue for
you and then start a show and have them
come on so you build a relationship so
he's been crushing that generating tons
of money doing it but what I want to
talk about with his channel is a
consistent thumbnail design so if you
look at his videos you can see he's
consistent this man is pumping out
content two days ago uh three days ago
three days ago four days ago he also
suffers from being too short right so
the the content should be much longer
two- minute video two minute video five
minute video it's G to be really hard to
get these videos ranking uh but we've
already talked about that so the key
thing for him is consistent thumbnail
design so the thing he has going for him
is he is in every thumbnail a lot of
times it's that similar kind of LinkedIn
profile picture that you see everywhere
but what you want people to do is
instantly know that it's your thumbnail
so what does a bow thumbnail look like
so in His Banner he's using you know
this blue and he's got this kind of aqua
color and if that's your color and
that's your font make that consistent
because it's so much easier for people
to see the videos one of the main ways
to grow your channel is through
suggested if you look at the big
channels you look at someone look at
Alex and I was growing it's through
suggested right it's not through search
we think of YouTube as the world's
second largest search engine and it is
but most of the growth from the big
channels come from suggested inside of
education and thought leadership what
that means is when I load one of your
videos and I'm watching
this I want to see your videos showing
up down the
side and this is where a lot of the
views will come and so every time you're
looking at one video then most people
even if they start with a search they
don't go back to the search results they
start going down the rabbit hole what
gets recommended to them and so this is
where you want to be showing up so the
challenge with a thumbnail design that's
all over the place even this one like
this one's done okay for Alex this is
not a great thumbnail for him because
you can't see Alex's face and so if I'm
skipping through this quickly I see Dave
Ramsey I don't necessarily instantly
recognize that that's Alex and so I
might pass it over even if I'm subscribe
to the channel even if I love Alex and
what he's all about because the
thumbnail design is way off and it's
hard to instantly know that that's him
compared to I know that this is Patrick
M David I know that this is Tony Robbins
I know that this is Tom Bilu you know
even Gary Gary could do a better job do
I know instantly that that's Gary ve no
and if I'm seeing it on the phone it's
going to be even smaller so harder to
see so Gary needs to fix his thumbnails
Alex needs to fix his thumbnails they
would get more suggested views it's the
same problem that Bo has here if I watch
you know if I see this and I look at
this and that's bow and I get this color
and font and layout and like I know that
this is what they're all about cool if I
see this video and I click on it and
then I'm watching it and then I see this
one show up down the side does that is
that bow I don't know it it looks like a
different guy and he's not in his suit
and it's a different font and it's a
different color scheme and so I might
watch this video and love it but then I
see this one down the side or I see this
one down the side or I see this one down
the side and because they all look
completely different I may not click on
the video so he was losing people who
want to click on his videos but they
don't instantly recognize him and so
that's what we want to do is we we want
to create a brand this is not anything
new to YouTube you want to have a brand
that is identifiable why do companies
spend so much on logos and fonts and
assets because it means something
because you want people to instantly
recognize you we've studied successful
people you know I've probably studied
more successful people than than most
people and the number one rule for
success is that you love the process you
have to like love the actual work that
you're doing that it doesn't feel like
work that it's we're all all trying to
have an impact and get result results
and you know you care how many views you
get Etc you know the the external
numbers but at the course you still have
to love the actual process and one of
the things that I love doing is being
able to pull rules for Success from
people who a lot of people may not
instantly connect with like Connor does
a lot of things that would throw a lot
of people off you know he's a he's a
lightning bolt he's he does he does some
things that rub people the wrong way and
they would never give him um a chance at
all to to hear you know some of his
wisdom but he's had a ton of success you
know and anybody who's had a lot of
success I want to learn something from
and doesn't mean that your goal is to be
the next Conor McGregor but you could
learn something from him and I've I've
tried especially to try to learn from
people who I may not like right out of
the gate for whatever reason because
they often have the most to teach you if
you only learn from people who are
exactly like you you're you're by
definition limiting how much you learn
so uh the challenge with Connor was
going through and saying okay I mean
he's got all these interviews of him
doing all sorts of crazy things which is
fine and you know Conor you do you and
there's also a lot of wisdom there's a
lot of wisdom you know if so that video
with Connor uh it wasn't him trash
talking somebody making fun of
somebody's mom or you know whatever else
but there's a lot of wisdom in there and
uh that's one of the things that I love
doing do you ever have moments where you
get out of alignment with your
mission uh yeah
not in a big way a lot of micro like
what um saying yes to the it's usually
it usually would involve saying yes to
something that I don't want to
disappoint somebody on but I shouldn't
have said yes I think we get a feeling
of whether something is good for you or
not right even come in here and saying
yes why this like my team is pissed that
I'm here because I'm behind I just came
from Arizona I'm going to Orlando next
I'm going back to Arizona and they like
we have this thing in the middle and
like hav't we need you on all these
Saints right and they're not H H but
like I'm now not doing stuff for my team
because this right uh but it's fine it
felt right talk to you it was great okay
we're going to spend extra time awesome
let's do it right even even our crew
here was helping helping set this up
right I was supposed to do a a a show
with Ramy
and and they said well why don't we come
here I no I didn't know him and I didn't
really know you so like okay well but it
felt right a lot of people are too
afraid to to share what the truth is and
it's easy to come with all these reasons
that are legit reasons but the real
answer is just like it's just fear and
that's okay and like even just speaking
it out loud about your background now
means the background has less control
over you you recognize how ridiculous it
is like okay now it's it's I've voiced
it it's it's kind of out of my system uh
and it and it allows for momentum to
happen um and easy way around it is uh
videos have to get made and this is what
I tell myself it's like videos have to
get made would I love everything to be
in my office and perfect sound and
perfect lighting and perfect everything
of course but videos still have to get
made and so last month I was on a cruise
and I went to Alaska and videos yeah so
for my videos for my main Channel with
three point whatever million subscribers
I go out on my balcony and I just take
my phone out I guess you can't see me
gesturing but just take my phone out and
I I press record and film the videos
from the balcony uh because videos have
to get out and so that uh putting that
in my calendar like this you could have
said no to this you know if this wasn't
in your calendar to meet me you could
have said I'm not gonna film today I'm
not gonna go live I'm not gonna I got my
background is all wrong right but it's
in the calendar and now you're you know
I'm gonna be going live by myself and
like where is she right so you have to
show up and so that's where you know the
commitment makes a difference and
especially if you're now going to commit
to coaching other people and they're
going to show up you now have to show up
even if on the day of you don't like
your background again you you still have
to show up because they're in your
calendar we need to be testing our old
videos updating the thumbnails and
titles on our old videos if you have any
kind of catalog of videos in your
YouTube account right now the single
greatest opportunity is to be split
testing the thumbnails and titles we're
so focus on what's next and we don't do
enough testing of what has come right
now we launch one main video every day
on my main Channel and we have an
internal goal to split test 100 videos
every day from our back catalog 100 new
split tests on thumbnails every day now
I'm crazy Nobody Does that right I've
got four people on my team and they're
just dedicated to doing that completely
but the single biggest opportunity if
you have any size Channel with content
on it the biggest opportunity for for
Gary VE for sha for Alex Heros for
Vanessa Lao for Pat Flynn for Evan
carmichel is to split test your old
content this is an example when I was
doing this I told YouTube it's like dude
this is crazy can we do a case study on
you and so they wrote this up as a case
study on me for split testing we took a
video here this video was done in
2016 we split tested it changed the
thumbnail in 2020 now first off this
video in 2020 would still get me 100
views a day a 4-year-old video was still
getting me views 100 views a day now
that's not insane but you're not getting
that on any other platform right nobody
cares about your Instagram your Tik Tok
your Twitter your Facebook your LinkedIn
your anything from a week ago let alone
four years ago so if you're trying to
build a brand that lasts YouTube has to
be the game for you I'm a believer that
everybody has the single most important
core value so for me I'd say believe
right so I I I want to spread more
believe in the world and whatever our
message is to the world is is still what
we need the most ourselves and the next
level of our breakthrough is on the
other side of even more of that thing so
my next level breakthrough is on the
other side of even more belief if
95-year-old Evan was going to come and
talk to me right now he'd say dude
believe in yourself more your next
breakthrough is on the side of even more
love and people might say Josh dude like
you're already the most loving person
that I know like how can there be even
more love but but that's the pursuit of
Excellence right like there's there this
isn't even the start of how much love
you could potentially share both both
internally like self- Lov plus love out
how do you bring more love to your
audience to the guests who come on to
the team who show up to the people who
buy your products and services as well
as to self and so um that's a frame of
reference that I use for myself at least
to say okay like the if I believed in
myself more what would I do what would
the next thing be because 95-year-old
Evan is is pissed that I'm not off doing
the bigger thing and it took me so long
to get here just like now looking back
it's like how come it took me five years
to get some videos going up to get past
2,000 subscribers not in a negative way
like you suck looking backwards but
let's use that as fuel going forward to
make the bigger play to to LEAP faster
into self-belief in my case to allow me
to go and do more because another one of
the things my mom used to say is if you
have the ability you have the
responsibility if you can then you must
and so uh I believe that if you're
someone who's filled with love you have
the responsibility to go off and share
like it's not enough to hold that for
yourself you have to go off and do more
with it like you can't settle for where
you're at right now my belief right um
and I think that's what Achievers kind
of hold themselves to that it's great
everything we've done and
I'm capable of more and more not just
for me but more to serve and to help and
to inspire and to spread more positivity
around the world the brand is usually
the biggest way to long-term have
success with your company but it takes a
while to build a brand I mean you've
been you've been at it you know lots of
people been added like it takes a while
to build a brand and a lot of people
fizzle out along the way and they don't
know how to generate immediate Revenue
which is where the other two shows come
in uh so if you need to make money this
year or right away like in the next
three weeks you can do it through
YouTube it's just not through thought
leadership content if you're doing
influencer marketing or you're going to
run pre-roll YouTube commercials cool
that's just direct marketing and so you
can do that you just track those lead to
conversions for you and that's
definitely play that's not where I would
be an expert at uh throwing somebody on
your team who's just at a university or
whatever that is usually an attempt to
build brand right we're trying to create
our own content somehow to build brand
uh is usually not a super effective way
to do it um but the direct marketing
side is very uh tangible is huge a lot
of people are doing it a lot of big
money is coming into YouTube because the
ad policies are are stric is but but
less strict than Facebook and Instagram
so people are getting a higher Roi off
of YouTube ads in they are on Facebook
and Instagram I don't know that I've
done anything every single day with
intention without fail um I mean the to
the spirit of the question the thing I
do the most consistently would be
injecting optimism into my life whether
it's a video whether it's a a book
whether it's um something that I you
know I I'm I'm reading on the airplane
or a a film that I'm watching a
documentary um injecting positivity is
probably consistently over the past 20
years the most consistent thing that
I've done now I'm very disciplined and I
have a lot of habits and most of my
habits I'm hitting 85 to 95% of the time
the health you know routine that we
talked about earlier you know but if I'm
traveling from here to Japan uh I'm
probably not hitting my sauna for the
day you know they're like just some
things that are not practical or it's
more detrimental to do it than not to do
it in some cases like it's better to go
and sleep than to go and do that thing
or it's better to serve because this is
a big opportunity than to go do that
thing so when it says you know do this
daily without fail I think the most
consistent thing is just injecting
optimism into my life and I'm okay with
hitting 85 to 95% consistency on on my
habits as long as you're proud for me as
long as I'm proud of the reason why I'm
not doing it right so even making videos
the only time in the past decade plus
that I have not made videos I made
videos when I broke my neck I made
videos when I went on tour I made videos
through everything the only time I did
not make videos is when my uh dog died
my dog passed away on on uh video day
and I was just this family dog for you
know 13 14 years and uh I just I was
destroyed and I could not make videos
it's you are what you consistently do
not necessarily what you do every single
every single day how important is it
then Evan to have une and to be the
expert in one area versus trying to be
the expert in every
area I think you have to be an expert at
the thing that you love right and
so we all can wear multiple hats uh
ultimately I think your purpose comes
from your pain right I think like
whatever you struggled with the most is
the thing you want to help other people
through
so when you're in a when you're in a
room you have to figure out okay where
am I further ahead than these people
here and in some areas it may be lots of
things right it may be you know so I I'm
I was launching my new book when I went
there right if I'm in a room of people
who have never launched a book I can
give a lot of advice on how to launch a
book if I'm in a room with Brendan and
Dean and Russell and these guys they've
sold millions of books so like okay I'm
not you teach me what I'm doing wrong I
tell me where I'm screwing up in my
process um but I'm still happy to help
people with their books right I think
it's just as you scale up and get better
and better and better
um your ability to influence is going to
just keep improving so you know we're
we're all in this staircase of growth
and we never want it to end you want to
grow forever you don't want to stop
learning and every time you take another
step up you can reach back and help
somebody else up but you can only help
people to the step that you're at you
can't help
somebody get up
there so whatever you want to learn and
get better at keep improving and then
you can keep helping people along the
path you know the advice I'm trying to
give is is is difficult because it
depends on who you're talking to so the
last advice I gave about sharing your
message well maybe you're happy being
the Larry King like maybe that's your
goal maybe you don't have an opinion you
don't want to be I don't know what Larry
King stands for he's a great interviewer
he's had the best of the best he ask
great questions but I don't know when he
when he's taken a stance on something
maybe he has but it's just not what he's
known for if you're watching and you
want to be the Larry King of your Market
awesome like don't worry about creating
your own thought leadership content
um in terms of finding a need
N I look at I love helping people
believe in themselves right I mean I
have a I have a bigger YouTube audience
than any of the people who was at that
event but I'm focused on helping people
get to where I'm at and there's a lot of
people who are who I used to be right
there's a lot of people who are at the
beginning stages I'm not focused on like
the high high high high Achievers I
don't want to be Brendan Bard's high
performance coach right
I'm okay with that I don't want to be
the niche guy at the top I want to help
the world right I want to help everybody
believe in themselves more um so there
just different models like what do you
ultimately want to do what's your
mission and then making sure that your
actions will ultimately maap your
ambition because I think people look at
somebody else say oh I want that but
it's not actually what you
want so figuring out that first like do
you want to do you want to speak on
stage and have a huge audience do you
want to be a giant YouTuber youber and
and have millions of people watch your
videos or do you want to be a super
select coach that doesn't need to be a
brand name but you're you're you know
how to do one thing and and that's it
and then you you're like the elite
player that people are paying six
figures a year just to work with what's
the point of a morning routine at least
for me it's to get a feeling so yeah a
lot of times people will just check the
box like I did this I did this I did
this I did this okay cool but do you
feel ready to take on the day because if
not then is either something wrong in
your routine or you did it uh
half-heartedly and you got to do it with
more intention um remember I was doing
an event in New Mexico and uh a woman
was in the front row of my event and I
asked her well what's the most important
part of your morning routine and she
said I do the rosary so she takes out
her her you know prayer uh the rosary
and starts doing her prayers I say well
okay so what's the what's the point of
doing the rosies like well by the end of
it I feel uh connected to what I'm doing
and ready to go and start my day awesome
how many times you actually feel
connected like by the end you doing the
rosary how much time how many times what
percentage of the days do you actually
feel connected and ready to go and start
the day and she said like
40% so the other 60% she's she's doing
the words she's doing the action she's
saying but she doesn't feel connected
because she's also stressed out about
something else because she's also making
breakfast because she's also watching
some video because she's she's doing
something else like well there's nothing
wrong with what you're doing you're just
not doing it with the intention that is
required oh great keep doing the rosary
but now focus in on doing it with the
right intention because the whole point
of the morning routine is to get the
feeling so I think a lot of a lot of
people a lot of um a lot of
entrepreneurs a lot of people who are
go-getters and action takers we love the
feeling of just like check check check
we check the box they did it but if you
don't have the feeling I've ready to
take on the day with boldness with
courage with service with belief then
either go back and do it again or add
something to your morning routine or or
tweak it up a bit because for me at
least the point of the morning routine
is to get the feeling so you're ready to
take on the day I come up with trigger
words so scary difficult hard are my
trigger words where if I think it if I
say it if I feel it if I write it if I
text it scary difficult or hard then I
have to do it just because yeah so the
fact that this question says you know
that they're afraid of starting do it
scary difficult hard if that was a a
reason for me to not do something then I
have to do it just because because I
want to be the person who does scary
difficult hard things because my my
goals my dreams are on the other side of
doing scary difficult and hard yes and
so we've accepted these reasons for not
taking action so if if I was this person
and and the the trigger word here would
be fear so you want to be the person who
does the things that you are afraid of
so anytime fear is the reason now of
course don't go jumping out of an
airplane with no parachute you know like
these are that's that's just stupid
right but allowing fear to run your life
means you will never have a great life
if you look at this category for example
this is 1 to 5 million impressions so
over the past 90 days these videos got
one to 5 million impressions those are
good to compare against each other and
you can find this on YouTube Studio as
well just look at the past 90 days look
at the Impressions and then see how well
the videos are doing so if you look at
this category as an example this video
here has 1.7 million impressions and a
2.3% clickthrough
rate if I scroll down we see this one
here this one's doing well Elon Musk
talking about weed here we go has a
million impressions and 7% clickthrough
rate similar number of Impressions
reaching the same number of people but a
vastly different click-through
rate these videos are worth comparing to
each other 7% versus
2.3% is a big
difference we need to go and fix these
videos right so in this scenario in the
one to five million impressions having a
2.3% clickr rate is bad when you have to
go in and fix it and we might work on
that thumbnail 50 times it it loses it's
still underperforming do it again test
again test again test again test again
what is your number one tip or strategy
to help us sell more understand your
most important
goal and then create the show that helps
you accomplish that goal like YouTube
can serve you in a lot of different ways
most people think of it just as a place
to be an influencer and build a brand
and and it is if you want long-term
success building a brand and having
people beat a path to your door is huge
but that doesn't happen in you know 30
days uh so if you're number one goal is
I need to make sales in 30 days cool
start a YouTube show I run Business
Development let's go close don't be
limited to people that you can actually
have a conversation with I've learned a
ton from what I call aspirational
mentors you know Steve Jobs is my mentor
Walt Disney is my mentor EP janini is my
mentor you could learn a ton from people
who've done a lot more than you this is
where people say well like I live in a
small town there's nobody for me to get
mentored by they all live in New York
City or whatever you could still learn
from those people listen to these
interviews that Michael does he's had
great people on board
watch their videos read their books you
can learn a lot from these people even
if you never meet them or if they've
passed on if this was 20 years ago you
wanted to be a Trader you might have to
go to Wall Street and go find a company
and learn but like how many episodes
have you done man like hundreds of
episodes yeah just go back and listen to
everything Michael has said and all the
guests that he's had on board you have
the access if you have a computer with
internet you have access to the
knowledge I think whatever your most
important core value is your who that is
your your heart
print so I want to spread more belief in
the world you want to spread more love
in the
world uh and so that's why understanding
what your who is becomes really valuable
and I split it into two things of the
thing that I'm missing the most is even
more
belief you know whatever that is like
people would look at you and say but you
are Mr love Ryan yeah but the thing that
you're missing even more is is more love
you want to transcend on the other side
of even more love more love for self and
more love for others and what does that
look like and when you figure that out
then like it's that you're like shedding
a new skin and now you're you're free
again and the same thing for me every
every major growth in my my life not
just business has been on the other side
of even more belief belief in self and
then trying to spread more belief out to
the world and so um I hope that uh that
that's what my heart print is a constant
reminder to me as well as what I can
create for others was there a moment
that you recall where this where this
Mission became very clear to you yeah I
talk about it a lot in in my book your
one word yeah
and I had my website and myb before I
had my YouTube channel had my website we
had 100,000 B of content and all these
big name people right to the website and
I was trying to figure what my tagline
was what's the slow bit of my website
and I I didn't settle anything that I
liked I had you know over million
entrepreneurs help the C and like all
these things and nothing really Li it
and I went to go uh Watch The Steve Jobs
movie uh and out of that I I the word
believe came
up and like I really like
believe but then I I can't like that's
too broad believe that's too it's like
it's it's ourselves we talk ourselves
out in the big idea so it's not even our
friends and family like you you have a
bold idea and then right away your head
tells you why you can't do it why you're
not good that so and then went okay you
can't just be believed but it's got
believe in self believe in entrepreneurs
believe it and like came up with all the
variations and I slept on it the next
day it came back any just like
believe so I I don't know let me let me
test it and so I sent the newsletter out
to my email let just talking about
believe and ended up me the best
newsletter ter of in G when clicks and
my sister said that she saw it and she
had she'd like the newsletter which is
like a compliment that the backand you
know theistic nuke that I made a video
about believe and my best video on my
YouTube channel had 100,000 views at the
time took a year to get there and I was
so proud of it 100,000 views is great
the video believe hit 100,000 in a month
and now was in a millions of of views
for that video and so it's not that
believe is the magical thing it's a
magic thing for me and so I I tiptoed
into it then eventually went all in on
just okay I'm going to be the believe
God that I still need it for myself and
I still need it like every time I learn
it I want to go teach other people as
well so my biggest strength is belief
and my biggest weakness is belief to do
the next thing why you started your
YouTube
channel uh I think your purpose comes
from your pain so I think whatever you
struggled with the most as a human is
what you want to help other people
through and so because I struggle so
much as an entrepreneur I try to make
content that I wish 19yearold 11 could
have seen
and I'm I'm what 13 years in when did I
start 2009 across all the channels we
probably recorded 15 20,000 videos like
how do you keep gr how do you not burn
out how do you I I mean I haven't missed
an upload day in a decade how well
because you feel like what you're doing
matters and so I always feel like the
content I'm making is to help even this
interview like when you she just pulled
me aside you know where at lunch I'm
leaving she's like can I interview you
why because I'm hoping that you know
somebody watches this video and maybe
that makes a shift to helping them
believe a little bit more in themselves
who are you who is Evan
carmichel just a human trying to make an
impact you know like I think to
different people on different things oh
oh cool uh you know so like at that at
that event with Ed I was focused on
talking about YouTube strategies you
know to to you here we're talking about
built to serve and purpose and introvert
right to other groups I'm I know I run
the largest salsa dancing school in
Canada it's har my wife in that group
they may don't even know my videos or
books but I'm I'm the guy who owns a
salsa company um right to my son he
doesn't care about any of that stuff you
know he doesn't care about my book and
my I'm a dad yeah so I'm I'm different
things to different people happy to
dance with with whatever energy they're
throwing out and um I'm just a human
when who wants to make an impact we play
small because we don't know how to
accomplish our big things and we settle
for the small thing yeah which which is
fine in the in the I'm going to I'm
going to twox or 3x my business knowing
that this is a base is going to help me
do my big thing but the big thing is is
unclear and that's also okay like the
the whole point of building the base to
3x is that you don't have to have the
next thing make you a ton of money yet
yeah but it'll lead
opportunities
so personal
finance being a thought leader there's
lots of options there's lots of models
that have already been proven out you
have to build the base right you have to
take it more seriously you have to
create more content you have to be more
powerful in your opinions you like
there's a lot of work that has to get
done but it's not that nobody has ever
done it so you make money from brand
deals from sponsorships from speaking
gigs from ad revenue from book launches
from your own products like the thing is
you won't know where you're going to
make the money until you start getting
into it you can have a plan but you
won't know until you get into
it for 10 steps to make this year your
best year ever check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there the point of it is that you can
have the best product in the world but
if no one knows about it what's the
point of the product I mean I would like
I'd like to know uh for instance if
there is someone out there